الحرب في اوكرانيا والصراع الدائر هناك
بين موسكو واكياف منذ ازيد من سنه رافقه
بروز شخصيات عديده احتلت المشهد السياسي
والاعلامي بشكل كبير فمن الجانب الروسي
طفت على السطح اسماء باتت ارقاما مهمه في
معادله الحرب شخصيه يطلق عليها اسم الصقور
قياسا بتاثيرها الكبير على مجريات الحرب
سواء عسكريا او اعلاميا ومن بين اكثر
الاسماء التي تم تداولها في الاونه
الاخيره والتي لعبت دورا هاما في المعارك
الميدانيه هو يفين
زعيم مجموعه فاغنر ريجوجن بات من دون
منازع احد اشهر وجوه الحرب في الوقت
الراهن بل اصبح بمثابه قائد حربي ولقب
بامير الحرب حيث قاد مجموعه من المعارك في
اوكرانيا
ابرزها في مخموت وتكفل هو شخصيا بتاسيس
مجموعه فاجنر سنه 2014 من خلال استقطاب
العديد من المحاربين والتجنيد الاف
السجناء
مشاهدينا باتا يظهروا بشكل متكرر من خلال
العديد من المقاطع المصوره كما يتكفل
بنفسه احيانا بالاعلان عن تطورات المحاكم
وشخصيه اخرى لعبت دورا هاما في هذا الصراع
من خلال التعبير بشكل مباشر عن مواقف
موسكو وخططها الحديث هنا هو عن الرئيس
الروسي السابق
والذي تحول من شخصيه ليبراليه الى احد
اكبر مؤيدي الاسلوب المتشدد في الحكم في
روسيا
لا يمر اسبوع من دون ان ينشر رسائل لاذعه
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ولعل ابرز
رسائل وجهها هي التهديد المتكرر بامكانيه
استخدام روسيا للسلاح النوويه
اما على المستوى الاعلامي فان الاسم
الابرز كان من دون شك هو رئيس تحرير شبكه
رشا توداي ارتي التلفزيونيه
هذه السيده كانت مسؤوله بشكل كبير عن
الجانب الدعائي من الحرب وتظهر
بانتظام في البرامج التلفزيونيه حيث تلقي
خطابات لتحفيز مواطنيها او تهديد الخصوم
طالت
الغربيه بشكل مباشر مع حظر فروع شبكه ار
تي التلفزيونيه في معظم الدول الغربيه